based here in the Columbia Heights
neighborhood of Washington DC lit city
is part of the district's thriving
gifting industry nine years ago the city
passed initiative 71 making it legal to
possess up to two ounces of marijuana
for personal use the law also created a
loophole allowing stores to gift their
customers small amounts of weed as long
as they also buy another item often at
an exorbitant price such as an 11 word
motivational speech for sixty dollars or
a ninety five dollar Spider-Man sticker
we came up with a
counties ants college fund Brownies so
you leave a donation you can take a
brownie and it became such a hit because
I was like this is my son's college fund
brownies and this is what's going to put
my son through college four years later
my son did graduate from Clark
University in Worcester Massachusetts